les derniers développements au sujet du
coronavirus sont à la fois encourageant
et inquiétant selon l' oms la situation
se stabilise en chine de sa dette
incluse par contre le virus se propage
rapidement dans d'autres pays
en corée du sud en iran mais aussi en
italie où les autorités ont isolé des
villes entières parce qu'elle ignore
toujours l'origine de l'éclosion
je pense qu'on a perdu le contrôle de ce
convoi nous tally ne sachant pas qui est
le patient zéro démontre bien qui a une
transmission qui s'est fait à bas bruit
à l'extérieur de la chine au cours des
dernières semaines
au canada la santé publique enquête sur
le cas d'une femme de
colombie-britannique infectées par le
virus
le 14 février dernier
elle est arrivée dire un nouveau foyer
d'infection
elle avait fait escale à montréal pour
ensuite prendre un vol d'air canada à
destination de vancouver
la femme avait des symptômes durant le
voyage
mais elle n'a consulté un médecin que
cinq jours après son arrivée au pays
on peut pas savoir quelque chose de la
personne ne peut signifier la santé
publique ne croit pas nécessaire de
contacter l'ensemble des passagers
présents dans l'appareil
seulement ceux qui étaient assis dans
les rangées près de la femme infectée
font l'objet d'un suivi
l'équipage d'air canada n'a pas été
placé en quarantaine
on est déjà si vous me permettez à 10
jours à peu près du vol d'avion les gens
s'ils auraient eu à développer la
maladie l'aurait probablement je
voudrais déjà peu de faire
l'intervention dans l'avion 3 devant
trois derrière cetc précautionneux et je
pense que je sais c'est adéquat un des
proches de la passagère vers canada a
toutefois été contaminées en colombie
britannique l'ontario rapporte aussi un
nouveau cas il s'agit d'une femme dans
la vingtaine
elle a voyagé en chine et a eu peu de
contacts depuis son retour au pays elle
se porte bien et demeurent isolées chez
elles ce qui est un peu rassurant c'est
que le virus n'a pas l'air plus sévère
qu'un virus de la grippe saisonnière
ici vincent maisonneuve radio canada
montréal